hello everyone after his brilliant loss
against Lebanon yesterday chakra alma
media decides the graces with he had
another interesting game and it was
really a Clash of the Titans today as
Azerbaijan was playing the sole leader
Russia and well it was quite the battle
on all four boards but this is board one
and this is mummy the Arab versus
Alexander Greece shook and like I said
mommy I've decided yet again give us an
interesting game so Greece Chuck has the
white pieces and he plays efore we have
E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop
to b5 the royal opus a6 mama D ro goes
for the Morphy defense Bishop to a4 d6
Greece to castles Bishop to d7 rook to
e1 and this is move six and already we
have had an interesting move by gamma dr
over here he plays g5 and i don't think
i've ever seen g5 on move six in the
real lopez but now that I see it I
absolutely love it I mean of course g5
why not it's it's spectacular
so Bishop captures on c6 big captures on
c6 and the d4 and Mama Dara now of
course pushes the pawn g4 night to be 2
and E captures on d4 so now he's up upon
Knight to b3 grease Chuck is threatening
to capture back the pawn and mamakara
plays Knight to e7 protecting the pawn
with c5 I would only improve White's
rapid development after a move like c3
for example
so after Knight to b3 97 was played and
Knight captures on d4 Bishop to g7
Knight to c3 Mahmud II era of castles we
have better up to g5 and it seems like
all the black pieces are really tied
down but here
Madera finds well I really think it's a
great move
he plays f6 calmly kicking away that
Bishop and well in the long run making
the f7 square available
for the king if needed so the rooks can
come to h8 and g8 Bishop to e3 now Queen
2 is a queen to e8 preparing Queen to g6
or h5 all depending Queen to d3 and now
Queen to f7 Queen to d2 was played and
now Queen to g6 not allowing any measure
up to h6 ideas better to f4
we have h5 b 4h for now a 4 and in this
position a lot of people would maybe
push g3 maybe they would push h3 and the
pushing h3 would probably be ok but you
don't go into the 2800 club to play ok
moves so mama Dara plays the absolute
best move he plays Queen to h5 h3 is
coming
either way white can't really stop this
but by playing Queen to h5 first he is
now defending the be 5 square so
depriving white of any b5 ideas
Bishop to e3 by Griff shook and the now
h3 we have Knights e2 e2 h captures and
g2 and Knight to f4 Queen to h7 night
after six and already we can see that
that night is occupying a very beautiful
square that is X square is amazing for
the night Bishop captures that the other
night captures back on e6 and Mama DRF
calmly plays Knight to g6 he doesn't
mind giving up this f8 rook that's doing
really nothing for this amazing night on
e6 and by playing Knight to g6 this
Knight now has ideas of h4 and f3 for
King the king and the Queen so Knight
captures on f8 rook captures on f8 and
the bishop to f4 now stopping the threat
of night h4 to Knight f3 with idea of
rook to a3 so the bishop had to move so
the rook can protect f3
f5 e captures an f5 and now 90 to h4
threatening to capture the F pawn and
also this beautiful fork Knight to f3 so
Greece truck stops this
to a 3 and we have Queen - Queen
captures on f5 now with a double attack
on the bishop on f4 Bishop to g5 with an
attack on the night and nice to f3 would
check now good if she has to give back
the exchange rook captures G captures on
f3 and you don't have to be a
particularly strong player to realize
that a white white is pretty desperate
here
Bishop to h6 now white would really like
to exchange the dark square bishop -
maybe maybe achieve some sort of a
perpetual check Queen to d5 my media
offers a trade of Queens he's up upon
and if the Queen's come off the board
and then black is practically up a piece
because the White King and g1 can't
really move Queens the c1 by grease
choke he doesn't really want to exchange
Queens like I said if Queen captures on
d5 simply seek seek after Sun d5 and
this is this is too strong of a position
for black
so after Queen d5 Queen to Siva or the
one by district and now Bishop the c3
offering to exchange more material
aggressive of course declines this with
rook to e3 if he plays Bishop captures
on f8 then Bishop captures on d1 and
after cwienke after screen captures this
Queen ending let's call it an ending
because it's really not an ending since
this skin can move the White Queen can
never move off of the first rank because
any dropping of the Queen and the first
rank is an immediate checkmate so this
would be too easy for black to play so
after Bishop to c3 rook to e3 was played
now attacking the bishop bishop to d4
again offering a trade of more material
rook to d3
now Gary stuck pins mama D our Bishop on
d4 rook to e8 getting out of the harm's
way since the bishop was attacking the
rook and also preparing a tactic that
Greece took obviously missed
c3 was played here a more resilient move
would be Bishop to e3 but even after
this move black is still winning
but after c3 this allows mama D are off
to end the game
pretty pretty stylish Lee he plays
Bishop captures on f2 which check the
kink has no square skin caster capture
the bishop King captures on f2 was
played and now rook to e2 check and in
this position grease Chuck resigned the
game it doesn't matter what black plays
if King did you want then simply f2 is
checkmate since the Queen from d5 is
protecting the g-tube bond and if
instead of King to g1 King to g3 is
played well look at that King and g3
this required some calculation on
maderas part but it was it wasn't really
a problem Queen captures on d3 I was
gonna be played and I'm Yara have simply
had to calculate that Queen to g5 check
led to nothing for white for example
King to have 7 and the white is pretty
much out of options if Queen to h5 check
Queen to g6 and all of whites hopes go
down the drain and if instead of Queen
to h5 check Queen to f4 of King to e8
and the well after white tries a couple
more things even Queen to f8 doesn't
really achieve anything
Queen to f8 check King to d7 and this
King will easily find a safe house after
King Theoden King to b7
the king will be safe on b7 and well
then moves like g1 Queen are coming so
after calculating that this was ok for
black that the Queen can't really
achieve any sort of a perpetual check
the game was over
of course Grisha resigned resigned the
game after rook to e2 with check so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and it was definitely a great day for us
there by John as they defeated the sole
leader Russia
mummy tiara of defeated Greece shook on
the first board Rajah the one on the
second board and Ralf Mamedov who is
unstoppable in this European team
championship won on board for so
definitely a great day for us or by John
there's one more round to go in the
European Team Championship so everything
will be decided tomorrow I'm very
interested
- who will take take this championship
so that's it I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Jia Wei Zhang
Charles Bartholomew an anonymous person
and norman harding for her contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank y'all for watching and
I will see you soon